these teenagers have all had to deal
with the trauma of childhood cancer they
faced months and in some cases years of
grueling treatment now they're in
remission they've come to spend the
summer in England they were all born in
Belarus two decades after the Chernobyl
disaster when you asked them what they
think caused their illness there's a
common answer yeah because Chernobyl
I think burrows is close to a crane and
in Ukraine was such a noble 13 year old
Alex had to have part of his stomach
removed to treat his cancer it must have
been very scary as a child I was correct
when they I've turned before yeah 14
year old Nikita was diagnosed with
leukemia three years ago a guerilla
doctor he's a chill mom he told me
doctors said he'd been affected by the
Chernobyl disaster the explosion of a
reactor at the Chernobyl nuclear power
plant in 1986 released large amounts of
radioactive material with devastating
consequences the nearby city propia
remains uninhabitable due to
contamination large parts of Ukraine
Belarus and Russia were affected but the
long-term impact on health is difficult
to assess studies have linked an
increase in thyroid cancer in the region
but links to other diseases are less
clear the uk-based charity Chernobyl
children's project has been working with
children from Belarus for over 20 years
and organized this trip to the Midlands
new cases are increasing any children of
their age some of the cancers are not
usually that high in the rest of the
world but the contamination means that
more and more children for generation
are still it's
the cancers and it will so four thousand
years Eureka's Menka is a doctor in
Minsk and has traveled with the children
to provide medical support radiation
effects cells and also genetics he says
their parents or grandparents could have
been affected by Chernobyl and it's in
their genes the aim of bringing these
children to the UK is to give them time
away from the environment where they've
grown up and the radioactive
contamination that could have caused
them so much harm Becky Johnson Sky News
Birmingham